hey everyone it's my photos and it is
Monday November 6 and I'm shooting this
quick video on this new indicator that
I've just in the process of releasing is
called Duval toes SNR levels and what
they are are support and resistance
levels that are derived from the order
flow basically it takes the order flow
you know I have certain parameters I'm
looking for in the order flow for market
generated support and resistance levels
and you know it's it's not some big
fancy calculation you know some view app
T web app whatever no you know it reads
the order flow I I try to make order
flow trading easy for people and this is
actually how I traded with order flow
when I first started trading with order
four years ago and you know just over
the years I've gotten so used to looking
for these spots in the order flow that I
didn't necessarily need to have an
indicator but you know people were
asking me you know specific questions
about it and I said you know what wanna
I just create an indicator it'll be a
lot easier for traders to understand so
a brief disclaimer this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or making an attack of
investment decision futures training
contains essential risk and is not for
every investor and investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
training and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider training
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results now the
tools I use in this our ninja trader and
the vault assassin are levels run on
ninjatrader it's available for a ninja
trader 7 which I'll be showing you today
and also ninja trader 8 so if you are
ninja trader 8 you can also use it you
can run it on the free version of ninja
trader so say you have you know you're
your broker zone front end system
running on your PC for trading purposes
and you know you just throw up ninja
trader on a second PC or your same PC
and run the charts you know as long as
you got a data feed you could use this
indicator with the free version of ninja
trader so I'm going to talk about the
gold market first I'm gonna talk about a
couple of markets but the first one I'll
talk about is gold now again this
indicator will run on an order flow
footprint chart volume footprint chart
as well as a bar
right now for ease of explanation of you
know showing you the markets I'm gonna
run it on a normal bar chart so just
bear with me let me get the chart up all
right so this is December goal now this
is a one-minute chart and you know again
this is this indicator to run on minute
based charts that are on arranged based
charts you know run take base charts
like say you use a nine eighty seven
tick charter or 233 tick chart you know
people like to use tick charts and fib
numbers but you know this this will
still work on they're on a different
chart type so what it'll do
so you see here right this red zone here
you have a red arrow for a sell a blue
arrow for a by then it'll draw this zone
this is the area where the support is
coming in right in this area and right
before it okay it's actually the selling
is here but I know that often times when
I have this set up in the order flow
that it's it's very common to see the
resistance of just you know starting at
that level and into that area or in this
case support right at this
you know white were the bottom of this
bar is down into you know then the next
couple price levels that's why it draws
out this zone and how you can use these
is for stops you know when you're
getting on the other side of it if
you're training above it it's you know
the reason for being in the trade is
over just you know as or if you're
trading below it if it's for a buy but
if you're trading it into it you know
that is where your resistance is or that
is where your support is and actually
you know you know the area right before
it the right now on the cusp of it you
know a tick or two on just on the other
side is also support you know it depends
on where you want to buy or where you
want to sell it's different ways you can
trade this but you don't want to talk
about here's is this gold market so this
is this morning Monday morning 7:30
you've got you know sign right here
where this red arrow is that there is
resistance in the market so how can you
trade it well one you could either just
get short immediately to you could wait
for a pullback and then take the trade
and you know if you're gonna wait for a
pullback you got to realize sometimes
the markets gonna pull back it may poke
through by a tick or two you know I know
you look at charts you know people these
trading experts trading gurus will put
up charts and they'll say
well you know it has to trade right back
to this point it doesn't but you know in
real life in trading sometimes you know
the market pokes through by a tick two
ticks three ticks on a pullback you
gotta realize right we just sold off
from what is this 12 72 30 you know you
sold down to 12 71 you know 40 a buck
and your rally back it doesn't only just
stop right at a level me sometimes poke
through you know trading is not an exact
science right and then sometimes you
know people analyze these markets and
they expect you know they expected to
come right back to a point it doesn't
that's not how it works you know there's
you know you if you traded the markets
you know exactly what I'm the point I'm
trying to make there so you know even
though it pokes through by a tick you
know it's not the end of the world well
you know it failed yeah if your stop is
right here then yes it failed you know
if you're given this you know two or
three ticks no it didn't fail again it's
it's a support/resistance area price
area not one particular price you know
it's it's funny because it's like you
see these you know the I said I've been
trading futures you know from JP Morgan
for Cargill for you know big firms and
you talk to these traders and you ask
them well why did you buy why'd you buy
at this level it look like you know it
looked cheap or you know here it looked
expensive you know they don't say well
you know we pulled back to exactly 61.8%
or you know like a perfect fit number
retracement right back to that one
particular price know they're looking at
an area they say hey yeah I think it's a
good sell here or hey I think it's a
good buy here you know that's you know
that the big traders the guys that move
the market that's how they trade you
know they don't sit there and say well
you know it's got a pull right back to
twelve seventy two point six for me to
get short I say hey you know coming back
home to this area here I think it's a
good sell here they they say sell it or
it comes back down here call somebody to
add you know I think that's a good
buying area I could buy it somewhere
down here that's great you know they
don't say well it's got a pull back it
pulls right back down to 12 you know my
fit numbers or whatever is saying you
know it's going to pull back to twelve
seventy one point seven and I'm gonna
buy it
well you can't sorry you're not gonna be
able to buy it at that area you know so
you know that's what kills me
about traders but anyway you know I
digress so you can see here right here
you know that there's resistance there's
gonna be resistance in this area that at
least there should be and what happens
the market sells off starts rallying
back and you run into that area that
zone where you have the you know
resistance selling coming in and you see
market sold off rally back up in here
now again this is zone you could draw it
out however far you want I think this
one I got set to 20 and you can see it's
it pulls back here again sells off pulls
back up that level sells off again I
mean you know I mean and finally it
broke through that level you know you
know they'll be these guys broke through
that level well come on I mean it's
really tested it once tested it twice
tested a third time you know it's how
can just keep bouncing there and coming
off forever you know eventually you're
gonna break through it and then you know
the markets you know this this level for
now is done basically and then you come
in here nine ten you got another level
kicking off now again don't think that
you have to buy in this area or sell in
this area there's different ways to play
it you could just get long immediately
you know you can get long right on the
cusp of this zone you get long inside
the zone you know I said there's
different ways that you can trade it and
if you got long you know inside the zone
great if you got long immediately great
if you got long just right on the
outside of it great point is you know
you got a trading opportunity how you
want to trade it is another story you
know where you gonna put your stop you
know put your stop you know just on the
other side of the zone just as you'd put
your stop right above this area and what
happens is this one was a nice move it
went from you know basically 1272 shot
up really quick actually all the way up
to seventy four point nine came off
again you know then you got a sell
signal here right this one you know two
bars later just popped up through poked
up through by twenty cents came back
down and then started rounding up again
you know I'm not gonna say well you know
support becomes resistance or resistance
become support because we never really
tested this level again you know this
was a resistance level that failed and
you know I'll see I would love to show
you the chart where it went from 1272
all the way up to what was it twelve
eighty you know you didn't run into this
thing but again you know
there's different ways to trade this I
know some people that you know with a
trade support resistance you know when
when it fails they like to go the
opposite way but a guy I'm not a big
advocate of that so anyway this is where
it gets interesting so you get another
buy signal up here this is what they
make this chart a little bit easier to
read here because you know you just had
this big run up here and so you know
what is this 1282 you got to move up to
1284 you got a couple buy signals here
and you got a sell signal here so you
know from 1282 up to what is that you
know 83 20 cents for a dollar and then
you run into the support area we got a
support area here you got a resistance
area here look how its holding this you
know so if you're buying it back in here
you rarely pack up you know from I mean
it's not the greatest rally I mean
granted you just had a $10 move in in in
gold now it's going to consolidate a
little bit which is what you're seeing
right here so you got another range
trading right so you've got imagine
right you got an indicator Nicky you
know help you get in on trends you got
an indicator that can help you trade
consolidating markets markets going
sideways you'd be buying it here you'd
be selling up here look you rally back
up into that zone and you sold off back
here again so you could buy here sell
there you know and cover it back down
here again you know if you want to get
long you know you you get long on this
one it cuts it stops you out here then
you got another buy here you know it
went up a little bit not much just like
a couple ticks sold off back into the
zone I mean it did poke one tick through
okay you know a fusion if you're want to
call it you know if you're gonna put
your stop right on the one tick past
this you get stopped out but you know if
you bought it here again this is having
you know low risk trades right if you're
gonna be buying it in the zone and your
stop is here you only risking you know
two or three ticks you find out where
you're gonna place your stop you know if
you're buying it here at 1282 the bottom
of this zone is twelve eighty one point
eight you know some of you got it at
twelve eighty one point seven you only
talking three ticks but if you're buying
it at twelve eighty one point nine and
you can get out at twelve eighty one
point twelve eighty two point five
that's you know you're risking basically
two ticks to get
you know five ticks whatever but anyway
yes it did come back in here rallied up
again you know you just had this monster
move now you're sort of going into this
period of consolidation but here
remember this one okay now remember
these zones right you could draw it out
however far you want you know and you
could adjust how high you want so you
want to make it four ticks you can do
that okay i-i've it on this chart I
haven't drawn out twenty and you got
this zone here right you had just had a
rally right so what do you have on a
rally right when a markets rally you'll
want to see supportive buying buying
that's coming in to support the market
and why is that important because it
could be you know a big trader you so
you got this market coming up because I
lot of sellers coming in but if they're
bidding the market but sellers are
coming in you know just right off a high
trying to sell the heck out of this
market but you have someone they're
absorbing all that selling that's going
to be important especially if you retest
it later so watch this let me just make
this chart a little smaller where do we
come back down to then we draw it out
for you here you know what I wants
rectangle here look at this look at that
this level here you sold off where do
you come back down to you come right
back down to that level we're on this
move up you had that support of buying
coming in here right you sold off into
that zone so if you were waiting again
you know if you're waiting for a
pullback at this area you know in your
you got bids stacked in here you know
1281 2012 81 you know and you just have
you know some stops here at twelve
eighty point eight you know even call it
twelve eighty you know fifty so you're
risking you know you're risking five
ticks here you know your rally up from
twelve eighty 120 all the way up to you
know just about twelve eighty three so
you're just risking you know three four
ticks to get you know 10 or 15 ticks
there you know then eventually you know
we just sort of went sideways here but
this was the move right this is what you
want anyways it's not you know trading
people try to make
a lot more difficult you know but
trading is actually really simple you
buy support areas you sell resistance
areas you know if they break down and
they're no longer you know if it breaks
down it's no longer support you know
chances are it's gonna become resistance
so if this market were to start selling
off I'd be looking for this area to be a
resistance area or you know right now
where are we trading here we're trading
a bit lower
what time is it discussion Allah is the
asian session here you had a level here
you know this one on the retest okay so
you know it shot up here in the next bar
or two again you know grant and this is
6:30 p.m. cago time you got a signal
there but you know again you look at
this if you know it's sort of just going
sideways here but if you were to draw
this out let's just make this again
support becomes resistance resistance
becomes support let's take a look at
this right you know people sometimes for
some whatever reason people you know
they always try to make training a
little bit more difficult than it then
it really needs you know if you draw
this out right I mean look at that
look how it's holding as a resistance
area again you know people say well you
traded up here for a couple bars have
failed yeah I don't know come again you
know it's it's a resistance area does it
it's not you know one pick that open
trades one tick through it's
automatically dead but you know that's
how it works right that's how support
and resistance work okay so what is this
this is the e-mini it's another
one-minute chart and I want just sort of
you know this market has a piece rallied
a nice rally today but you can see you
were running into some resistance
selling honestly whenever you make a new
highs in the ESPYs it really feels like
you're running into resistance and you
know after the cash open here at this
high you sort of ran into the resistance
area did sell off I mean it sold off a
point you know about four ticks again
you tested it again here eventually it
rallied back up so I mean you had a test
here sold off you had a test here and it
sold off a little bit but not much again
you know it's it's it's tough sometimes
when you're selling
and the recipes are making new highs
because you just you really run into a
lot of size and you know S&P is at this
point you know when you're running into
new highs you do run into a lot of
levels with so with some very strong
volumes now here's one you know this is
this high up here at 9:30 and getting
out 25 87 even if you're waiting for a
pullback up to again to test that high
87 3/4 you know down to five and a half
five and three-quarters you rally back
up we're still you know we're still in
this the zone right here alright if you
were to draw that out or is that here
you know again if you were to draw that
out right you come back up here 25 88
you know you can you can give it a try I
mean you know if you're selling it at 88
and you got to stop up here at you know
eighty eight and three quarters or even
89 you know two ticks through imagine
again you're selling it at 88 you're
risking a point but you can get back two
points you know from 88 down to 86 you
know it's about managing your risk and
in training that that's what training is
about you know eventually you know again
you're training a one minute chart 9:30
you know at some point you know I want
to look for these levels - hold on a
1-minute chart all the way up until
until the close but you know we sort of
came back into this area you hit it
you're sort of just hanging around here
hanging around here eventually you make
a new high again at 2:00 o'clock and
again similar thing first time you hit
that new high here you got you know cell
signal but what does it do it trades
right back up into the zone again you
get another cell signal here right after
it's actually about 10 minutes later
don't make the new high you trade just
on the cusp of this but again you know
if you're trying to get short say you're
short here from down what this is you
know say this is what eighty nine and a
half say you get an offer in here at
eighty nine and three quarters you know
inside this initial zone
you're not stopped out of that position
I don't think you know again if you
start throwing some offers up in in here
at 90 and a quarter 90 and a half you
don't get filled on those of it you're
filled on there your trade from in here
and you're patient you know what is that
you
9 and 3/4 what do you trade down to 87
86 and 3/4 here I'm not saying you would
have gotten filled at 86 and 3/4 but you
know if you can get in at 89 and 3/4 and
you're out at 87 and 3/4 that's 2 points
you're risking one point and you getting
back two points now you know this is I
like this indicator because one of the
things you can do with it among other
things you know I've I've got a more
instructive video on it now these two
charts that I've showed you I've got
volume thresholds volume threshold of
2000 so it's gonna tell me that if you
know in this case is the e minis it's
got to trade at least 2000 Lots in the
bar so here later you know at 3 o'clock
3:30 when you know cash is closed and
volumes are a lot thinner I'm not
getting signals because you know maybe
it's trading 600 contracts in 1 bar or
you know 30 cos a 30 but you know if
it's not trading and enough volume to
give me a meat what I would consider a
signal that's going to be meaningful
that I'm not interested in it and the
gold one I had set to what was it as 500
I could see it right there
so again honestly to get 500 in the
night session at 6:30 is that's before
Asia opens up is is actually quite
strong so I have a feeling this is this
was a decent level I would have liked to
see more of a rally off of that
but when we broke down through it you
can see how you know support became
resistance he traded back up in here you
came off again sure to trade back up in
here went sideways and sold off again
you know how can you train it you know
you can trade the breakout you can trade
the breakout you know if you're not sure
if this is support or resistance at this
point again it's at 6:30 this is at
10:00 o'clock I'm not sure you'd still
hold it as a valid level for hours later
but if you were you know you trade
breakout you just bracket your orders in
there I stopped sell stop you get you
know buy stop here you get in but it you
got a sell stop to get out okay then you
got a sell stop to get back in and again
you want from twelve eighty down to
twelve seventy nine so okay I'm not a
big advocate of trading some of these
markets in the evening sessions but if
you were that's how you can do it I mean
there's many different ways to trade
this so its I'll show you the euro
currency your
see he had a big move but on you know as
far as this indicator went because I was
using a support resistance level I was
using volume threshold of what was it
500 so then nothing actually showed but
just give me a second here I think I had
one that had no no threshold just bear
with me one second here but I've got all
these charts open up sometimes it gets a
bit confusing okay actually no this was
it again so this was this morning here
so you had a sell signal here this is at
what time just 42 o'clock you know a 750
or something but look okay so this one
set the volume threshold of 500 because
you know if you set it to zero and you
know you could get a lot of it a lot of
signals flash in which you probably
don't want you know you want to get you
know when you're dealing with support
resistance right you should have a
decent amount of volume traded all right
I mean you know would you look at a
support level where the bar trades you
know 100 contracts as important or a
sport level where the market trades you
know a minimum of 500 contracts because
you know support is where buyers are
going to be coming in in size to stop a
move lower where a resistance level is
going to be an area where sellers
willing sellers are coming in to defend
that price area but look at this right
if you were to draw this out again you
could draw this out on the settings if
you just go to the indicator right just
open it up here was it you over here
it's this one plot with 20 or I have it
set to 20 you can draw it out a hundred
if you want it's it's up to you I prefer
to try and keep my charts clean and I'm
able to look to the left but again if
you want to draw it out you can okay
here let's draw this out here but let me
look at this okay so you know we're in
this range here okay so you got a
resistance level here you got a support
level here right now you can get short
here immediately
and it comes down to this area it's not
the biggest move but you know you're
coming into an area of consolidation but
if you were you know getting short here
on what this is 15 okay you get a buy
signal here ten that's ten ticks but if
you know you got it resistance selling
up here right you see you put your
orders here that's it you mean you sit
there
you have a gift fill to get filled if it
doesn't get filled doesn't get filled
simple I mean that's the whole point of
buying support and selling resistance
you know wait for it you know and you
know how most people trade it is to say
you know let's see okay well we've
traded here we traded here you know they
might not pick this up because they're
not looking at order fall and this
doesn't look like a resistance level
honestly but I know that in the order
flow they were strong selling here so I
know that if we come back up here you
know there might be resistance again
doesn't mean all that every time and no
but in general that selling that was
there is still there when you retest it
just as you can see here I was buying
down here we test it there's some buying
comes here you know what it look
optically better if you didn't poke
through it by one tick if that was the
low of the day but again you know
sometimes these things poke through it
by one tick you know when you're
kneeling with support resistance levels
and you're dealing with pull backs right
you the markets rallied from you know
what is this oh seven we'll call it all
the way up to 17 then you sell off 10
ticks doesn't always stop right on a
dime right at that bottom you know you
know it may poke through it by a tick
again it's the support and resistance
level not price so but again the other
point is you know they're selling up
here you put your offers in up here for
the market to retest that it's simple he
tested a sell off you mean that's 10
ticks right need to come down here you
got buy orders in here waiting for it to
come back in it by you and it does it
comes back up and sells into that zone
again yeah it's not gonna sit here and
consolidate forever right and once this
resistance level breaks down it's gonna
be you know it's gonna be your support
area so again yeah I know people that
will have pie stops up here so when we
do break down when this resistance level
break down there long there's different
ways to trade support resistance
although there's not just one way and
you know again if you get in on trends
great if you could have a way to trade
consolidating markets great you know I
mean being a trader isn't having just
one method that works you because the
markets don't just trade in one method
sometimes they consolidate sometimes
they were you know trend so if you got
to have a ways to take advantage of it
you know it's not like you know you sell
you're a car dealer and you sell just
one car no you got different models
because you know different people are
gonna buy different cars just as in
trading you know the markets going to
these different market types
now again you know I'm not saying that
you would have bought it here and caught
this monster trend you know if you
remember the market rally hugely there's
no Trump let's say Bigley off that but
again you know it's giving you some
decent trading opportunities you know
you get low risk right you have a sell
right in here you guys stop just you
know right in here a couple ticks above
it you've got a bye-bye limit here got a
you know your stop to get out down here
if it comes through here to stop you out
but again you know it's look at this
right so you have your your level here
you have a level here now most traders
you know they'll see this they won't see
this part here you know this is
something that just came out in the
order flow but what they'll say is well
you know you had had a swing high here
you got a swing high here so this is
your resistance instead you know by
using the order flow that you have
resistance selling here so you could be
waiting for it to come here you're not
waiting for this to trade and then this
to trade then okay well we get short if
we come back up in here you're missing
this trade you're missing this trade you
know what to get this that doesn't work
all right you want to get in as early as
possible oh I don't think there wasn't I
don't think there was any more say all
right I wish there was a buy signal here
that I could look like a million
dollar guru but no that was it but there
wasn't that signal there I mean the
interesting thing was that that
consolidating market at that time and
how it held those levels looked at you
got one opportunity to opportunities
three four five this one didn't come
back down here
but you know then you know the breakout
of the failure of this resistance area I
mean cuz you can imagine right you're
trading here sideways sideways sideways
sideways in basically uh you know 1215
tic range you know from oh 6 to 1618
stuck us sit here all day and I mean it
can but generally it's not and once it's
you know it's like a rubber band right
you wrapped the rubber band around your
finger sooner or later it's gonna snap
off and what's gonna happen is it's
gonna go who knows where right and I'm
not saying no at this point you know
it's gonna go up or at this point you
know it's gonna go down you know when
you're sitting right here but you know
if you know the markets right you know
it's not gonna sit here in a tight range
all day that it can snap out and you
know you can either get a big move up or
a big move down so you got PI stops up
here you know when you when you break
this area all right you got cell stops
here if this were to break down to catch
those moves so anyway um you know uh
this is video actually I was thinking of
making about five minutes it turned out
to be almost a half hour this is a new
indicator and it's available for my
inner circle or if you want to buy you
can buy it separately I mean you know
people have been asking me about it but
you know I've got a presentation I'm
doing a webinar with investor
inspiration on Wednesday
if you ever registered you should
register I'll be talking more about this
indicator and hopefully showing you some
more examples but you know again you
know this is the beauty of order flows
because you can read what's happening in
the market which trading in the market
you know people think that volume
doesn't matter
yeah I really beg to differ you know I
mean some people are they're adamant
they're set in their ways of trading and
saying that oh no volume doesn't matter
okay oh I'm not gonna convince you
otherwise but you know if you can't
treat all prices the same and that's
where indicators fail most of the time
is they treat all prices the same and
you know not all prices are created
equal you know it could trade 500 lots
you know you could trade one lot or 500
lots at a price and it's gonna have
different meanings in the market you
know I mean it could trade 500 Lots here
a lot of different meaning if it's rated
just 20 lots you know just like in here
you may think you know there's nothing
here but there was something in the
order flow in the volume telling me that
there was resistance in here strong
sellers in here to support the through
hold the market down from going higher
we're going back up right cuz you're
coming down you got a little bit of
buying coming in here why didn't the
market go back up it was because you got
you got some strong sellers in there
period you know that's that's how volume
is useful in your trading now again you
know people go you know if you're such a
great trader why you you know why you
created indicators and selling them why
don't you just trading them well I've
created you know my entire professional
career you know people that know me know
my background but you know it's the way
I look at it is you know you won't you
want to be good at something you know I
I struggle with you know people the I
struggle with but you know I get upset
when I deal with people I call wet
noodles right who basically just want to
be handed stuff don't want to understand
the market and understand how to trade
because you know then they become jaded
and you know trading is competitive and
you want to be competitive in the sense
well I'm not sure competitive is right
word right you want to be competitive in
the sense of being good at something
right and being excellent at something
and believe me nobody's more competitive
than I am and you know sometimes when I
do get envious but of other traders but
it's not when they do something that's
absolutely spectacular it's because you
know maybe I wish I had taken that trade
or something but that's not to take it
away from them you know I sometimes I
just wish that you know there's trades
that I don't take that you know I wish I
did and you know going back to you know
being good at something and being
competitive as something that's you know
you want to be competitive so you know
you could be honed in and ready to go
and you know one of the things that you
know these these people that you know
internet trolls or whatever you want to
call them you know is saying oh if
you're such a good trader you know why
you're selling this information is
because you know you want to get out
there you know people sometimes think
that you know the upper the top shelf
right to show for all the good stuff
is you know is there's actually infinite
right it's not like there's no space up
there for you being taken away by
somebody else that's training well no
you know there's room for everybody up
there you know and that's my goal is you
know get traders that are struggling to
get them you know up there and you know
up there to a better level of where
they're training in their training and
you know being successful and you know
basically just being good at trading
rather than pissing away money on shiny
objects or you know spending five
thousand dollars to sit down through
some quote intensive course training
it's not complicated you know it's not
rocket science there is some science
behind it but you know if there's
there's one thing if you take away is
you buy support
you sell resistance and previous stops
you know basically become bottoms and
you know you break through a support
level it becomes resistance you break
through resistance level it becomes
support you know those are you know you
don't need to spend tens of thousands of
dollars to understand that now where it
comes in with order flow is order flow
allows you to see you know the volume to
make a better guess on something as
being a report or resistance area and I
hope you get in earlier get in as soon
as you know that there's going to be a
support area so again you'll imagine
right you you you know here right you
know here's a resistance area okay so
you let you litter this area up in here
with some offers okay because you think
in the if this is support we're gonna
come back up here and test it and if it
really is support it's gonna hold and
markets gonna sell off okay so what
happens the market sells off what do you
do your rally back up into there your
rally back up into there that's what
resistance does just as support here if
you know that this is going to be
support if you can make an educated
guess with the information at hand I
mean that's all you can do is make you
know the best possible guess with the
information that you have and with order
flow I think you just have a little bit
more information than other traders
rather than sit here okay well I got a
low here I got a new low here you know
I'll draw a trendline here and call that
but even if you draw a trendline right
you don't make a new low here so if
you're trying to buy it down here you're
not gonna get filled but if you know
in this area there's some support of
buying in the market you put some bids
in here alright and you know what
happens you get filled a market trades
back in there are tested if you're wrong
you get stopped out okay fine
you know you get stopped out then you
look for the next trade you know that's
what trading works it's about taking
small losses when you can and that's a
majority of your losses hopefully with
these small losses but you take the
small ones and then you you know you let
the ones that aren't losses you know you
let them run the course for a nice
winners so again you know you're buying
it here so you're buying it at oh six
you got to stop in at a toe five you're
risking two ticks you know but you're
buying it at oh six you know back up
sixteen you're risking two ticks to get
ten ticks
so you know that's what trading is about
and don't try to over complicate things
sometimes you know traders do again I
try to make order fool very simple and
put it in everyday terms for for people
to use so you know hopefully watching
this video you know you hear my rambling
may resonate with you may not try to
record more videos I've been going
through a lot lately with some timely
issues but hopefully now things are back
on track and I'll hopefully get more
videos off you but again you'll register
for the this week's webinar and you know
I'm gonna explain a little bit further
some of the thought process that goes on
with this this new indicator and again
how you can use it in your training so
thanks everyone have a great day bye bye